what was your favorite meal in Italy and
in what city was it I love meat and
Florence is a town of meat so we kind of
were on meat overload every night we
were getting these big steaks but that
to me was fantastic
and also I wanted to share a lot of this
stuff with Conan and the other members
of the crew because I'd been going by
myself and I've been talking to these
guys so years yeah you go by yourself
please see what I'm with even after
getting married you go by yourself and
you take selfies of yourself in romantic
restaurants alone true or false this is
all true I believe I believe there is a
virtue in traveling alone it allows you
to interact better with the people
around you and with the environment at
Bundy felt the same way when I'm eating
a steak with you I'm thinking about
whether you like the steak when I'm
eating a steak alone I'm thinking about
how much I like the steak narcissist
my favorite meal by far was we got down
to Naples we went to this restaurant
where they had a pizza margarita
now people talk about I think this is
the best pizza I think that's the best
pizza I love pizza all the other pizzas
are here the pizza I had in Naples would
be above the ceiling of this studio it
was the best
what is the name of that place a genius
or below is the place that you saw there
they are I just I ate that and I it was
one of the most divine experiences in my
life even within Italy people think you
can get a good pizza everywhere which is
not necessarily the case but Naples is
the town of pizza and that place is my
favorite
you